Buonasera mi chiamo tahar Lammari e
vorrei parlarvi di paura di xenofobia e
di ostilità verso il diverso
la paura
generationfobia e ostilità verso il
diverso e da questa da questa sentimenti
e passioni che corrompono profondamente
la società facendole perdere senso
civico e umanità
e contrario ai fatti e alla ragione
pensare che rifiuto dei diversi sia
compatibile con l'amicizia fra i
cittadini
quando la paura si scatena quando si
diffonde non sappiamo fin dove possa
arrivare il gruppo sociale percepito
come pericoloso non è immutabile
varia a seconda delle circostanze e può
benissimo ricadere in un altro su un
altro gruppo sociale questa paura
altrettanto fragili o privo di mezzi per
difendersi
amicizia e ostilità non possono
condividere lo stesso spazio
così lo stilista finisce per invadere
l'intero spazio sociale
per estensioni successive
ma non tutti hanno paura allo stesso
modo
Chi ha affrontato le onde del mare
mettendo a rischio a rischio la propria
vita
può aver conosciuto una paura che
possiamo definire
possiamo definire reale
soggettiva individuale
chi rifiuta L'altro invece
conosce una paura collettiva dove
Paradossalmente viene rassicurato da un
sentire collettivo cioè si sente in
qualche modo protetto solo da chi ha
paura come lui
Buonasera mi chiamo Maria Rosaria
Mancini e lavoro in prefettura
di recente nella mia esperienza
lavorativa mi sono scontrata con la
paura In diverse occasioni in
particolare in due circostanze che hanno
avuto un impatto significativo
quando siamo stati in presenza di grandi
recenti grandi flussi migratori con
numero con numeri che non c'erano mai
stati in passato sì C'erano stati però
erano stati più sporiatici più
occasionali e poi sono diventati
soprattutto dal 2011 sono diventate una
costante poi l'altra occasione in cui ho
toccato con mano la paura è stata la
pandemia di covit
queste queste due realtà le ho vissute
ho cercato di viverle da diversi punti
di vista dal
punto di vista di chi arrivava in italia
degli immigrati che arrivavano in Italia
di chi in Italia c'era già e di tutti
noi che abbiamo convissuto con la
pandemia la paura è il filo rosso che le
ha unite tutte la paura di chi faceva un
viaggio dall'Africa o dal Pakistan per
arrivare in un luogo che non conosceva
la paura di Chi abitava già qui e si
vedeva invaso la paura di chi
aveva paura a vedere intorno a sé una
malattia viveva una malattia sconosciuta
e la paura di tutti noi di perdere le
nostre abitudini
da Lampedusa non si entra da Calais non
si esce da Ventimiglia non si passa
da Belgrado a Budapest si viaggia in
vagoni piombati
aseuta Emilia in club spagnola spagnole
in terra d'Africa
come poi al confine tra Bulgaria e
Turchia o al confine tra Ungheria e
Serbia si alzano reticolati e muri
ormai è stabilito che le linee di
confine sono i corpi dei migranti il mio
confine arriva fino alla linea in cui ho
stabilito che sta partendo un migrante
per arrivare da me
L'immigrato non aveva paura
aveva fiducia in una vita nuova che lo
aspettava in Italia in Europa anche se
non le conosceva Chi era qui invece
aveva paura perché non conosceva
L'immigrato lo percepiva diverso da lui
e gli faceva paura
i cittadini avevano paura della nuova
malattia perché non la conoscevano aveva
stravolto la vita di tutti aveva
distrutto i punti di riferimento che
erano rassicuranti che l'avevano
rassicurato per tanto tempo Poi la vita
è ripresa la paura di diminuita Qualcuno
ha trasformato la paura in rabbia e la
riversata su chi era colpevole di avere
distrutto questi punti di riferimento
è vero è vero che L'immigrato arriva
pieno di fiducia ma è anche vero che
negli ultimi anni si è diffusa una una
paura nuova che ha investito i figli
degli immigrati ragazzi Nati e cresciuti
in Italia ragazzi che si sentono
italiani a tutti gli effetti ma che si
sono sentiti all'improvviso esclusi per
via del colore della pelle o
dell'origine dei genitori
alcuni anni fa
intervistai Vangeli nato è cresciuto in
Italia rientrato in Senegal poi dopo
qualche anno tornato in Italia per una
tourné teatrale e Mussa mi disse
mi capita spesso in Senegal di pensare
alla mia infanzia
vissuta a Ravenna ci penso alla luce del
senso di paura che mi invade ora nelle
strade d'Italia e mi dico Loro credono
che io faccia paura ma sono loro a fare
paura a me e temo che la mia infanzia
venga divorata inghiottita da questa
paura che questa paura diventi che
questa infanzia diventi Per me una Terra
straniera
il mondo attuale è complesso può fare
paura la paura genera incertezza genera
rabbia però è necessario superarle con
la comprensione il prefetto in questore
gli uomini delle istituzioni Vagliano le
informazioni
le informazioni scientifiche
costruiscono procedevano costruire
procedure che debbano aiutare la
cittadinanza la popolazione e
contribuire a rassicurarle L'uomo delle
istituzioni con l'interpretazione della
legge e la creazione di procedure aiuta
ad attivare la razionalità di di tutta
la collettività invece l'uomo di cultura
lo può fare toccando la sensibilità
delle persone utilizzando anche forme
d'arte
comunicando in modo adeguato si attiva
la fiducia e la comprensione e si può
disattivare la rabbia
negli anni novanta avevo una vicina una
signora anziana una signora di Ravenna
che nelle giornate belle nelle giornate
di bel tempo stava lì si sedeva lì nel
cortile e leggeva i rotocalchi questa
signora non aveva mai visto in vita sua
un nero l'aveva visto sì in televisione
nei rotocalchi che leggeva ma mai così
di persona Un giorno mi viene a trovare
il mio amico modu gay
Allora lei lo guarda non dice niente poi
la sera dice a sua figlia
in Q a Ios un negher
ma l'era negher
Ma così nero che aveva persino le pieghe
del collo nere
e lei dicendo così
è come se fosse riassunto di
decine di Trattati di Antropologia
perché lei era una bracciante abituata
all'abbronzatura dei contadini e i
contadini ovviamente
si abbronzavano il collo ma le pieghe
del collo rimanevano rigorosamente
bianche e per la prima volta vede
arrivare un nero che aveva persino
queste pieghe nere e quindi le pieghe
sono l'intimità e lei dice
Oggi ho visto il diverso
lo riconosco e ho le parole per dirlo
partendo dalla mia vita
un altro aneddoto che mi viene in mente
e che due giorni dopo il mio arrivo in
Italia a Ravenna nell'aprile del 1987 un
sacco di tempo fa presi l'autobus per
andare
a Punta Marina a salutare il mare
è una mia abitudine non so per quale
motivo ogni volta che vado in una città
vado Cerco un corso d'acqua un fiume il
mare un lago e vado a salutarlo e al mio
arrivo
cioè sono andato ho salutato il mare e
poi tornando sono tornato alla fermata
dell'autobus e lì è arrivato un signore
anche lui per aspettar l'autobus e mi ha
detto qualcosa
io non capivo l'italiano quindi lo
guardato come chi non capisce No quello
che ci guarda così e non
negli occhi magari C'era il vuoto Non so
ma comunque l'ho guardato come uno che
non capisce
le parole di questo signore e il Signore
si avvicina verso di me
Prende la mia mano prende la mia mano
così alza la manica della giacca Guarda
il mio orologio
mi aveva chiesto l'ora
e quindi per nulla intimorito dal mio
silenzio del mio essere diverso mi tocca
e mi dà il più bel Benvenuto che si
possa dare a uno straniero in Terra
straniera
per concludere quale potrebbe essere
l'atteggiamento del cittadino Il
Cittadino dovrebbe poter ascoltare e
fidarsi degli elementi della conoscenza
che gli vengono dati attivando la sua
coscienza critica e utilizzando tutti
gli strumenti per approfondire ciò che
non conosce
spesso la conoscenza è un atto di
fiducia coraggioso serio io scelgo di
fidarmi di ascoltare di valutare tanti
elementi che potrebbero rimanere
sconosciuti però in un processo a due
vie io mi fido di te Tu però mi devi
comprendere
[Applauso]